please join me in giving a warm welcome
to Shawn lady
thank you Andy
and thanks and thanks to all of you for
the for the really warm welcome out here
on stage wow there's a lot of people in
this room I've been to every three
except the very first one from Atlanta
from LA to Atlanta then back to LA I've
SAT what all of you are sitting now but
never thought for a second that I might
have the honor and privilege of being on
this stage before all of you and while
it is a great honor to be here I got to
say the strongest emotion I'm feeling
right now is excitement and and more
than a little pressure but I'm
completely and utterly thrilled to be
here as you've witnessed already the
thirst for innovation at PlayStation is
tremendous our lineup of genre and
blockbusting titles is a testament to
that and our desire to bring great games
to all of you is matched by our
commitment to bring a great gaming
experience throughout the world of
PlayStation so let's start by talking
about PSN our network is robust and
ever-evolving to deliver the experienced
gamers want and we have heard loud and
clear what you're looking for powerful
ways in which to share your experiences
and connect with your friends and the
growing PlayStation community to that
end we continue to bring new tools to
the ps4 faithful to enable that desire
for shared experience such as share
factory and the photo mode and second
son and we'll continue to enhance our
features that redefine how when and
where gamers play a quick look at that
reality is frankly awesome nearly ninety
five percent of ps4's worldwide are
connected to the network and the social
activity is astounding more than one and
a quarter billion hours have been spent
gaming more than 1 billion multiplayer
sessions have been played on ps4 since
launch that's a lot of death match
the share button on the DualShock 4 has
been pressed 220 million times as gamers
invite friends and the community to
check out their gameplay and that last
metric will climb even higher when we
bring YouTube to ps4 later this year
with the simple press of the DualShock 4
share button ps4 gamers will be able to
quickly upload video captures to their
YouTube channel you will also be able to
see your friends shared YouTube videos
in your what's new activity feed ps4 is
also the first console to allow you to
live broadcast and spectate game
sessions already more than 150 million
spectate sessions have been viewed on
ps4 and we're constantly innovating this
experience as well look when you're
watching at home some schlock horror
movie sometimes haven't you felt the
need to or the desire to scream at the
television screen look out behind you or
don't open that door well now only on
ps4 you can effectively do just that
while spectating and they will get the
message not only can you watch someone's
gameplay in real time you can now
interact with that person's game
experience while they're playing you can
help them you can harm them it's up to
you but you're right there with them
this is another way we're going to
redefine what social gaming can really
mean this summer we will further enhance
ps4s broadcasting capabilities with some
new content for the playroom the free
DLC will allow you to easily create your
own custom broadcasting sets so you can
further personalize your message and
content for the widened gamer wider
gamer community
never losing sight of what has always
made PlayStation great we're using the
network to bring you more of what you
want awesome gaming experiences games
that are epic and challenging and games
that are more accessible such as free to
play we're committed to making gay
playstation the best destination for
free to play games free to play offers a
great way to discover new worlds and
experiences and we think this category
will explode on PlayStation in the
coming years right now we have more than
25 free-to-play games coming to ps4 in
the next 12 months including kingdom
under fire to from blue side planetside
2 from Sony Online Entertainment there
you go and guns up from Valkyrie
entertainment and on PlayStation at
point of entry free-to-play means free
to play let's take a look at that